are you guys ready to play yeah yeah
Sonny suggest which sibling is more
social suggesting they might be better
at parties okay they used to tell me
when I was three I would grab people at
weddings and just dance with them out of
nowhere did that last week oh we all
said oh this taking that party title I'm
gonna say I'm the life of the party in
all situations well you did love a good
party do the parties so it's actually
middle children no one guessed right oh
okay hold me back on a study found which
sibling tends to be a perfectionist I
don't think we even have to discuss no
we just all know I want to say all
together anyway three little little if
the scientists science trend this way
for instance we were cooking those leg
egg wraps from that cookbook whoo shank
it right the first time you made it the
next day your plan to make a man yep
Emily you guessed right
it is oldest children oh you're right
I'm just trying to not be a
perfectionist which sibling has been
shown to be most empathetic of the
family how it is I think he knows it
well I definitely think that Jessica's
list of the fattest of all of us because
you're very sweet and kind
you're always been like a follow-up text
sent users what do you think's on this
test
oh yeah oh geez I don't know exactly yes
that's right
younger children have been shown to be
the most pathetic
you